الخلاف واضح بين واشنطن وكييف على خلفيه
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد تنقل صحيفه وولو
جورنال عن مسؤولين امريكيين واشنطن سبق
وان نصاحه اوكرانيا بتغيير استراتيجيه
الهجوم فبدلا من نشر قواتها على جبهات عده
من الافضل تركيزها هجماتها على مناطق يمكن
فيها تحقيق اي اختراق الهدف من هذه
الاستراتيجيه الوصول الى بحر ازوف تستند
النصيحه الامريكيه بحسب ما تنقل الصحيفه
الى حساب حجم المساعدات العسكريه الكليه
لاوكرانيا والتي فاقت ثلاثه واربعين مليار
دولار على مدى سنوات قليله وبحسب مسؤول
امريكي فان حجمه ونوعيه هذه المساعدات لن
تتكرر حاولت اوكرانيا الدفاع عن تكتيكاتها
الميدانيه وغيرت من نوعيه هجماتها وباتت
تستهدف بشكل مكثف شبه جزيره القرم والعمق
الروسي ثم تصريح مفاجئ من الرئيس
الاوكراني يقول فيه ان نقل المعركه للداخل
الروسي محفوف بالمخاطر ليتحدث الرجل ايضا
وربما للمره الاولى منذ اشهر عن حل سياسي
ممكن في القرن مجله يزوي كانت تحدثت عن
وجود خلافات متزايده داخل القياده
الاوكرانيه بسبب الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
المخيب للامال بحسب الصحيفه وتضيف نيوزويك
انه بات على الرئيس الاوكراني الاختيار
بين بدل كل جهد ممكن وبالتالي المخاطره
بفشل مكلف او خفض خسائر اوكرانيا وقبول
هزيمه مدمره سياسيا لكن اكثر ما تخشاه
واشنطن بحسبريد جورنال ان تكون معركه
اوكرانيا ضد روسيا قد دخلت في طريق
المسدود